but now we begin with bad news because
you were meant to be here in the studio
yeah i was meant to be there with you
and i'm really sad not to be able to be
there today yeah right
no truly because i love traveling with
pedro when we are promoting a film i
love your show i love london it was
going to be a short
nice fun trip but
wasn't possible oh well well it's lovely
you're here in zoom land that's terrific
but there is disappointment among the
guests uh james i know you were looking
forward to meeting penelope again i
nearly left
this is why i was here um
to smell you
[Applause]
just to be near you uh yeah but you have
met before we've met a couple of times
yes yeah i remember we met at the
bathtub yes we did
i was very excited to see you
uh i was presenting the best actress
award and of course you want it because
you're the best actress
um
yeah she won and uh don't look so
surprised
you probably directed her because you've
done like 90 of her film and
as she came towards me she went i am so
glad that it is you and i was like
i've seen your imitation of me before in
that show
i know what you do
um she goes i'm so glad it's here i'm so
glad you and as i presented her the
bafta i kicked her really hard in the
toe
i don't remember that you don't no but i
promise you next time i see you i will
be able to do your accent and i will
intake you okay
i i love it and do it brilliantly or do
it badly i'll love it either way i must
say we've got a picture of you backstage
at the baftas and uh
just look at james here he i mean
you look like the cat that got the
you know lipstick when i was younger for
some reason my lips used to go
incredibly light and people would always
say to me are you wearing lipstick and
i'd be like what but yeah you're not
wearing lipstick i'm not
[Music]
you